[MUSIC PLAYING]
RETO MEIER: We're joined now by
Adam Seligman, Vice President
of Developer Relations.
Now I love the theme of
last night's keynote,
Get to the Fun Part.
Can you talk a
little bit about how
you chose that
theme, and why you
feel it resonates
with our developers,
and really all
technical practitioners?
ADAM SELIGMAN: Yeah, you bet.
Thanks for having me.
It's exciting to be here.
Keynote was super fun.
And the whole idea was
to really celebrate
what developers and operators
actually do every day.
You know, hopefully
they're spending hours
a day productively building
apps, running apps, deploying
apps, monitoring
apps, and not dealing
with all the other
stuff that you normally
have to do when you build
applications, especially
in the enterprise.
Getting out of Waterfall
and getting to Agile,
not just throwing over an app
over the wall for someone else
to operate, but taking
ownership in a DevOps culture
and operating, and really
removing all the barriers.
Everything from not having to
manage and shard databases, not
have to manually manage your
VMs or even pick VM sizes.
And really just get to the
heart of building applications.
And then let the Cloud
take care of it from there.
That was the spirit we wanted
to capture in the keynote.
STEPHANIE WONG: So
configuring networks,
rewriting apps due to
Cloud provider changes
and waiting around for
build, test and deploy,
are clearly not the fun parts.
Didn't Google once face
these sort of issues?
And how were we able to
remedy that at such scale?
ADAM SELIGMAN: Google has
built a lot of great software
to run these services
that billions of people
use every day.
So a lot of, a couple
of decades of experience
went into how do we help Google
developers become incredibly
productive so they can spend
an hour, six hours on average
of writing software every
day, and absolutely minimize
everything else in the chain
of getting to deployment
and getting that service
out to production, where
a small number of users can
test it as a canary deployment,
and start giving you feedback.
So we're trying to build
that into our Cloud.
We've seen the rise of DevOps
practices out in the industry.
But now we're building
into our products,
with products like Cloud
Code, like Managed Kubernetes
and CSP, Cloud Run, our
new serverless offering.
Just really reducing
the barriers
that anyone, like
a Google engineer,
can build code and
get it in production
as easily as possible.
RETO MEIER: Fantastic.
Now if you had to pick just
one, just one best practice
from yesterday's keynote that
you want developers to walk
away with, what would it be?
ADAM SELIGMAN: I'm
going to cheat a little,
and instead of like
I think Google said,
I really like what
Twinkle Desai,
who is a VP at
Kohl's, who started
her career as a developer
and a unique sysadmin.
And she built a lot of
automation at Kohl's.
Now she runs, a
couple years later,
she rents a 200-person team.
They have a 100 microservices,
5,000 containers,
it's all automated.
It's running on
managed GKE On Prem.
She said they've been through
two big holiday shopping
windows, which in retail,
is a really big deal.
So I'm thrilled
that Google Cloud
can support retail customers.
But by making her
people super productive,
it's been really great for
Kohl's and really great
for her career.
STEPHANIE WONG: And that's an
inspirational customer story.
We also saw incredible downloads
during the keynote yesterday.
Can you tell us
about some of them
and which one was your favorite?
ADAM SELIGMAN: There was a
couple that were a lot of fun.
I really liked what Wicks
is doing with Google Cloud.
They've gone from being like a
drag and drop web environment,
but now it's
totally programmable
and extensible Google Cloud.
That's really exciting.
The opening demo that
Mandy Waite led us through.
Her dev team is taking us
through was very, very cool.
Because it was a
mix of developers
doing VM-based development,
with Jenkins for deployment
of new VM images, a
container-based app
in the middle, and then
extending with new services
with functions,
serverless functions,
which is pretty cool.
So to see all those teams kind
of working together and using
tools like Cloud Code, our new
IDE integration for VS Code
IntelliJ, just awesome.
People can work the
way they want to work.
It all works together.
All runs on Google
Cloud seamlessly.
One pane of glass
with Stackdriver
to observe and manage it.
And I think that's great.
Let developers do what they
want and get to the fun parts.
STEPHANIE WONG:
That's fantastic.
Thank you so much again for
joining us today and giving us
some of that great information.
[MUSIC PLAYING]